ciao ragazzi bentornati a una puntata di
vita di cucina buttata oggi faremo
finalmente una ricetta che prevederà il
meraviglioso ritorno del microonde
partendo dal presupposto che io le
patate le odio battuto né le mangio
solamente e le apprezzo tanto in due
modi fritte ovviamente è il secondo è
sotto forma di pure a me ne piacciono le
patate per fare il più grande di fronte
avremo bisogno di patate parmigiano
grattugiato fresco bianca bontà bianca
punta può essere qualsiasi cosa anche
mamma mia cosa hai capito che sta
stringendo
no no niente sono solo malpensa con
latte del burro duro classico basile no
non era bianca a bontate infine noce
moscata
questo è ovviamente opzionale ragazzi
nel senso che mi amerà sempre visto
neppure voi andate agosto allora
cominciamo con questo probabile incubo
si fa infine sacchetti da forno che
vadano anche bene per il microonde
chiediamo scusa che siamo solamente e
gianmarco ma stamattina enrico ha deciso
di non svegliarsi ha detto a gianmarco
scusano noti raggiungo di legioni
modellino ce la faccio adesso arrivo
arrivo e si è rimesso a dormire abbiamo
richiamato un'ora e mezza nuovo e ha
detto che forse verrà sempre se non si
orienta le sue movenze del paleolitico
arriverà questa che è una delle cose più
pannosa in assoluto
guglielmo che stai facendo no e mi sono
svegliato gianni liberamente dormito 4
ore perché le patate sugli occhi avevano
un bene assurdo e anno grazie loro
succhi delle proprietà pazzesche e che
ti fanno oh mio dio proprio divano
commuovere scusami per i quali le patate
non riesco a trattenere un alacre quindi
ora mangiamo le sue parate
sì sì sì è un modo per uno di vanto
lui è bravo usare il coltello mit
immagino nelle sfide tipo dell'ottocento
quelli tra bande
mica non so usare il coltello per
uccidersi usare il coltello per pelare
le patate ma che tutti quanti siano gli
assassini e adesso quello che
bisognerebbe fare è tagliarli a pezzetti
e in finale tutte quante all interno di
questo sacchetto non troppo grandi in
modo che sarà più facile cucinarle ha
dentro e poi anche le spopoli con la
forza del pensiero ce l'hai tipo un
martello da cucina un martello da cucina
si certo hai presente della cucina come
il cacciavite rapagnà che usi dopo per
il derby del momento della verità
prendiamo le patate le mettiamo qua
dentro e non ho mai usato un sacchetto
da forno e ho visto che un sacco di
persone li usano pure per il pollo
ammettilo non hai visto dalle persone
che usano il forno ma l'ho vista con
pensione questo è un meccanismo
particolare messo questo cosino qui
propongo che si inserisca quel dentro a
questo punto si ferì no bellissimo e
adesso è il momento più divertente
sì la grande incognita la sbattiamo nel
forno a microonde per lo devi sbattere
sciami macho durissime sono molto dure
dici di amare idea di come usarle rischi
essere come tanti maschi là fuori
il microonde tower resa non lo dicono 15
minuti
si vabbè facciamo gli agenti mangiati
che adesso noi finito questo
procedimento avremmo dovuto pulire la
pentola con tutta quanta la merica ce ne
facciamo tutto dentro quel sacchetto a
quello serviremo ticosa cut off
a tra poco boriello quando mancano 20 di
rischio natale fratello tale fratello
padre del re figlio che ponendolo da
fratel a fratello mi interessa quanto
mancano ancora sette secoli sentito
degli strani rumori il materiale che ha
colto rumori nè se perché scoppiettare a
breve lo stoppiamo lo tiriamo fuori
giriamo in pole faccia le muoviamo
perché secondo me le cose microonde che
rimangono ferme troppo a lungo non può
non porre come dio è un lamento
terribile si stanno facendo
bravo rompere leggermente già i
legamenti che le legano ok basta non
voglio esagerare
la cosa consiste ragazze che non
sporcate niente cioè quando non è
successo mai a un certo punto bisogna
anche essere onesti nei confronti al
proprio pubblico e ricordarsi che non
bisognava deluderlo che proprio le
persone che ci seguono il danno delle
aspettative da parte nostra e quelle che
secondo noi sono pari a zero non è che
possiamo di colpo dai gatti riuscire
essere bravi a 30 secondi
a chi è anche sta qua dietro a darci un
altro colpo
[Musica]
giorno band svegliata dibattito è chiaro
che dopo noi dovremo comunque al nero
con latte per ottenere la giusta
consistenza perché adesso è proprio
patate nos presente infatti tre minuti
di vita di fare anzi cosa fatta le in
film doveva permettere di cucinarlo
meglio ma stazionando vediamo se il
microonde renderà vittoria questa volta
perché è quasi sempre un fallimento però
quando è una vittoria è forse una delle
più dolci se tu riesci in poco tempo a
fare un piatto convincente è una
vittoria travettore guglielmo combatte
per i diritti dell'umanità bado a fare
piccola ma sì cos'ha detto
si no che è fatto gianmarco gianmarco ne
possiamo dare un altro ce la siamo pieni
di fossa
ma perché potete una luce indietro ma
c'è una luce dietro vabbè c'è ora che
siamo ripresi petto tutto estati a
combattere i diritti del mondo va bene
sono così importanti ma eppure appena di
fine anno abbiamo sporcato niente
possiamo anche dire che poteva andare
peggio ma io non so più chi permesso di
avvicinarti ma le mie ricette ma come
faccio io devo riprendere fare il kun è
stellare il pure con una mano non devi
farlo lei lacerato accuse ha detto gli
stava dalle marche gian marco lai presso
la girato e soprattuto così cominciano a
massacrarlo comunque mattarella non l'ho
fatto apposta ma che faccia capire come
si apposta per comunque ripreso da
quando hai finito di riparare i danni ma
ci siamo per sette ore
abbiamo il nostro sacchetto inizierei ad
aggiungere direttamente nella busta di
perugia il mar colombus teniamola latte
quanto ci metti a top
dobbiamo incominciare a fischiarlo
massaggiandolo al fine di incorporarlo
molto delicatamente ragazzi come se
stesse massaggiando dell'efaf ma non
essere mal pensante dolcissimo quel modo
di papà ma sembra curioso lo sa imporre
ancora caldo quindi subito bureau dura
ci metterà molto poco marina che stanno
ri attesissimo aggiungiamo a questo
punto bianca bontà
basta e datevi anche con le ma ti
avvicinano italiane del bisogno e quindi
non si dica regali al sì io sono
solamente dalle gare anche a livello di
sanità mentale sale te lo sai
massacrando da un'ora interrotto
fra spia manca la noce moscata scherzo
aggiungendo sempre dentro al sacchetto
che di provare proprio non dover mai
versare il composto all'interno di una
ciotola cosa che in realtà vi consiglio
di fare se volete anche essere più col
giocatore magna dal sacchetto messer di
grande noce moscata
la mia quanto su quello che vi consiglio
di fare è evitare di massaggiarlo così
senti vuole farmaco si dall'alto verso
il basso in modo che i prodotti che lo
mettete sulla superficie possano subito
scendere sul fondo come le favole o per
vedere il regalo che mi ha portato da
amsterdam molto molto carino capito
ancora che cosa sia è un interesse senza
veramente un toccante uno fa così che
finirebbe no no basta allora abbiamo
cadere questa va montando un video
segretissimo segretissimo riteniamo ha
assaggiato una sola volta mentre
possiamo sempre fatte le faccio una
cucchiaiata perché siamo arrivati al
momento in assaggio alla come sempre vi
ricordo di farmi sapere quasi tutto
quali sono delle ricette che vorreste
vedere iscrivervi a questo canale se gli
piace altrimenti è bello a capirvi quei
cosi di passaggio sotto la lente
metterci un pollice in su per il
soprattutto enrico così per punirlo o
per fargli un favore ci però saperlo e
basta attenzione lui elmo spacca spacca
al lento ingozzati che essendo già qua
la seconda porchettata della pizza al
piatto esagera è la prima sentiamo come
oggi fanno fan piatto 8 scappavano io
non voglio spiegare
ma curata e ricorsa contaminato un
livello dentro
da allora perino che schifo oddio messo
il maggiore orribile allora rispetto
[Risate]
rispetto a oppure standard poteva essere
un pochino più cremoso dove li forse un
po di infilarmi nel mi do un po più
salato anche per i miei gusti e anche
più formaggio zoe il formaggio su certe
lo senti si sa però che posso di ken
esperimento riuscito ma l'esperimento
super riuscendo esperimento riuscito
l'unico consiglio è però è osceno dono
tanto a microonde fate attenzione quando
lo spacco laterale strugge il sacchetto
e ad avere tutti i pezzetti perché a
volte qui ci stanno per i piccoli
brunini non danno fastidio e squisito
comunque è veramente buono dyer e
dall'altra forchetta va supera le mille
tubi e superati funzione meglio posso
aiutare come i piccioni come non
bruciava
manteniamo martedì con la puntata di
ciao ciao